ok so it's a it's a simple that doesn't
actually get used that much which is an
R with a little cross with a circle
around it after it as a suffix at the
bottom of the the symbol and the R is
for radius and the cross with the circle
around it is the astrological symbol for
the earth and so it's the radius of the
earth is the symbol yeah it's kind of in
the news again now I mean you know the
radius of the earth it's sort of fairly
mundane well-known quantity but it's
become a big issue again because people
have started discovering all these
planets outside the solar system and
obviously the big question that everyone
wants answered is are they like the
earth and so one of the simplest
measurements that you can make is to
measure the radius of them and say well
if the radius is kind of you know maybe
one or two times the radius of the earth
then that's a planet that's earth-like
whereas if it's say ten times the radius
of the earth that's the radius of
Jupiter for example so that's a
jupiter-like planet so it's not like the
earth so it's really a way of measuring
whether a planets like the earth or not
by measuring its radius in Earth radii I
mean the whole field of looking at
planets outside the solar system we've
exploded you know it's really I mean in
the last 15 years that we've found any
planets outside the solar system at all
and now we're up around four or five
hundred planets known outside the solar
system but the reason why it's a big
story at the moment is a new satellite
has gone up a telescope called Kepler
and Kepler's whole job is to try and
find more and more these exoplanets and
they've just released their first
results that the telescope's been up
there for a more than a year now but
they've actually just released their
first results and they found about about
five planets just from the it was sort
of the first six weeks of data they
looked at and they're already rumors
that there are many more planets in
there as well it uses a technique called
occupations and the basic idea is that
if you happen to have a system where
you've got a star and a planet orbiting
around it and it happens to be exactly a
John then every time that the planet
goes around the planet comes between you
and the stars now the planets a lot
smaller than the star so it doesn't
block out all the light of the star but
it blocks out a little bit of the light
of the star and so some tiny fraction of
a percentage of the light point 1.0 1%
of the light of the star gets blocked
out by the passage of the planet in
front of it and this telescope is so
sensitive that you can actually measure
those tiny little dips now it's a little
more complicated than that because there
are lots of things that can make stars
vary the sun's output varies a bit when
there's a solar
gets a bit brighter and so on so there's
lots of ways that stars can get brighter
and dimmer but if you see this
characteristic signature of the signal
dipping in a periodic fashion so
regularly every time that the something
orbits around it then you really got a
pretty strong indication there is
actually a planet in orbit around so the
neat thing about this technique is it's
actually one of the few techniques you
can actually use to measure the radius
of a planet because of course the amount
of light that gets blocked out depends
on how big the planet actually is big
planets block out more the light little
planets block out less of the light and
so you can actually get a pretty
reliable measurement as to how big these
planets actually are and they're now
finally getting down to the sizes of
planets that we are kind of comparable
to the earth so the smaller that they
found is about four times the radius of
the earth so you really are getting down
to now fairly earth-like planets still a
bit bigger than the earth but really
getting to that sort of size
I mean it's not a particularly well
defined quantity for example do you
measure to the lowest point on earth
which is the bottom of the Pacific Ocean
somewhere do you measure to the highest
point on earth which is top of a
mountain somewhere do you measure to sea
level and of course the the earth easily
exactly round because it's rotating it
actually ends up bulging out a bit in
the equator so it's about 30 or 40
kilometers bigger at the equator than it
is at the poles it's a bit squashed and
so there's lots of different
measurements you can make you can make
but in terms of actually you know
comparing the size of the earth to other
things it really doesn't matter that
much all you really need to know is the
radius of the earth is a little less
than 6,400 kilometers does that mean
that earth radius is a bit like the wave
journalists use Olympic sized swimming
pools or double-decker buses and
football fields it's just to help give
an idea of scale exactly it's a way of
just measuring the size of things and
it's you know it's a useful thing partly
because it's something that sort of
people can slightly relate to but also
because line behind it there is this
question is this a planet like the earth
and so measuring something in Earth
radii gives you an immediate feeling you
know it's four times the radius of the
earth so it's not quite like the earth
but it's not that different from the
earth or its twenty times the radius of
the earth then it's really not very
likely other tool does something have to
be similar to the size of the earth to
have earth-like conditions that's not
really clear I mean the what the problem
is there are lots of things that go into
you know whether a planet ends up like
the earth like you know how close it is
to its stars or whether water is liquid
those kinds of things one of the
important things is what the gravity is
because obviously if the pull of gravity
was ten times what it is on the earth
then things would be a lot more squashed
if the pull of gravity is a lot less
then there's you know the less to hold
things onto the surface so for an
earth-like planet you probably want the
pull of gravity to be comparable to the
earth and so one way of doing that if
something is the same density is the
earth if you want the pull of gravity to
be the same then it really has to be
more less the same size now one of the
interesting things about these planets
that are just being discovered with the
Kepler satellite is they're not all
comparable in density to the earth
there's this ridiculous planet out there
which actually has a density that's sort
of comparable to styrofoam incredibly
low density planet so actually you could
end up with earth-like gravity on a
planet which is a completely different
size from the earth so in the light of
these new discoveries we may actually
have to kind of change our views a bit
about what planets really are worth like
is not a new question at all people have
worried about it I mean ever since
basically ever since you started
thinking the earth might be round and
the obvious question to ask is well if
it's round was his radius and so the
first sort of scientific attempt to
measure the radius of the earth was made
by a Greek guy Eratosthenes about 200 BC
and he came up with his very clever he's
amazing guy he was an athlete he was
interested in geography he was
interested in astronomy mathematics so
cause sort of amazing wide range of
things he did but one of the things he
did just along the way was measured the
size of the earth and the way he did it
was very clever essentially he looked at
how high the Sun was in the sky where he
lived and then went a few hundred miles
north and measured on the set of the
same on the same day at the same time or
got a friend to do it because you can
get there instantly to measure how far
how high the Sun was in the sky on the
same day and of course as you go around
the surface of the earth
you know if the sun's overhead in one
place if you go north the sun's no
longer overhead it's a bit sort of lower
in the sky and so you can actually
figure out in going these few hundred
miles what fraction of the circumference
of the earth he'd actually gone round
and since he knew the circumference was
you know two pi times the radius once
he'd figured out what fraction looks
cumference he'd gone round he could
figure out what the whole circumference
was and hence figure out what the radius
of the earth was and he actually got an
answer that was right within a few
percent by making that measurement and
that was the kind of the classic
measurement of the the radius of the
earth for centuries afterwards